hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to let's play black
snow okay if you notice I have more
health than I did before and it's been a
while since I played my last one because
I had some trouble because I had so low
health and I had no way of getting
health that I literally could not
progress so I had to revert to an older
save which wasn't old enough so then I
had to start all over and work my way
back to here fun times but I'd do
anything for you anything hmm
okay enough of that nothing silliness
now oh you guys have so kindly suggested
that to announce that I have a key card
and I have a blowtorch ergo I can go out
and go to the place where on the other
side of the map where there is a
generator or something like that and I
can blowtorch the P door hey I don't
know I haven't seen it so I'm gonna just
assume that it's something cool and
amazing like that but other than that I
must I think I can make it if I hurry my
little butt off I'm not sure though
off camera those black monsters are
still a son of a [ __ ] and I hate them
is it
is this it ugly no no no this isn't it
this is the hanger balls no I'm just
gonna I just gotta load cuz that way we
will be okay alright there we go okay so
now we are back in it to win it and
where am I
oh wait no oh there's the map there's
the map in the UH it's a nap in the
little room that I'm gonna go check once
I find out where it is I'm gonna be all
over it
you obviously can tell that I am a
professional gamer of sorts I know how
to beat these things and not just scream
like a little girl I have more use than
just being ridiculously good-looking all
right okay guys
okay the generators actually behind it
how do I get back there oh no oh oh no
oh
either have to go around the shed or
back through the building cuz I know
where that is now that's back in the
beginning I just saw it ah here we go
thanks for the building that I'm not
gonna be able to navigate this sumbitch
alright so now we're gonna be sitting
here for a little bit on the
unbelievably long loading screen just
you and me oh whoa
house quick ah man okay I don't know if
there are any heaters left I don't know
where they are anyway so I just gotta
wait for these shadow douches to come
over yonder away
hello where are they
are they here them how are you hi okay
so now that you're there I gotta make a
break for it
happy bday do-do-do-do-do-do oh god no
I'm trapped in this room now oh this is
a bad choice uh slow down cold milk was
a bad choice okay so we're here maybe go
just kidding just kidding just kidding
brah huh you know how I like a kid I'm
such a kidder okay go go yeah ha ha it's
so damn dark ah heater heat me aha
yes oh thank goodness gravy there's a
heater a humidifier because the way the
text e-text said and meant that there
was like some sort of thing with a black
goop that was a parasitic cellular
organism though has been on every planet
or something you know you know how that
makes sense
Oh God finally have health oh it's so
nice to have felt again so nice so so
nice I like this I like this a lot I'm
so glad that this heater has full
heating juice ah what this 100 virgin
health Hot Diggity
AHA let's waste it ha ha oh no no ah
bollocks I can't see where I is oh wait
no this is it got my way [ __ ] ha
[ __ ] you oh no that was not it Oh
way the other way that I need to go haha
oh god those Jewish bags okay so it was
through this door here don't give me
don't give me ah that's true here no way
it wasn't through here loser here ah oh
no this wrong you're an [ __ ] you know
that
fine kill me my body is ready kinda
maybe not really so where was this there
was like a damn like ah aha
I have no health again vaj you know what
let's gonna go back again good now I
know I take a left turn not a right and
then I get on my merry way you see
anything so damn dark you got heavy
balls aha
no get my ah yeah no no hi yeah I'm the
best not really but I'm okay I'm alright
thanks for asking
let's see what we can do
come on skip to my Lou
okay that's uh yeah boom BAM [ __ ] oh
yeah oh yeah
ah I use a stocky card yes yes blue new
great success okay that is not something
oh come on can I get some humanity some
nice company a cup of cocoa why does it
have to look like I'm descending into
hell why is that have to be a thing I'd
really like have a nice environment for
once I mean don't get me wrong people
who made this very very nice I pooped it
how bad do you want me to Boop it going
offline what no go online go online this
Buber is not pooping I Boop it so hard
and it refuses to boot back what a dick
well let's just carry on then save for
them who is this another pooper oh no
the biodiesel pressure is low it's in
the green so is that good if it be this
low on bug
I don't trust this Oh
oh so bright yay okay I got two cans of
biodiesel wait why do I have to am I
supposed to fill up one of these
generators with one of them get my
solution
tell me if I'm solution we go back to
that other room see if I can sploosh
over there cuz maybe this will help get
how wha oh hello the other pressures not
high Bret pressure no high yeah well I
guess we're I guess I'm done here hi the
ignition key there's gotta be something
else down here some some OOP was I say I
forgive you I forgive you oh no no no
huh let me give you let me give you what
was the point of that is that nothing oh
nothing I thought that was gonna be a
traffic sure so I have to ask what is
with this blooper wait hang on a car
fuel oh okay refill tank oh uh where do
I tank her do i tank Oh fuel here ah all
right so wait for gage to go green wait
that gage in the other room aha smart
smart smart guy just yellow
aha for you you [ __ ]
oh [ __ ] you [ __ ] you so hard oh god
damn ah ah no everything's pastel again
it's all film noir I noticed the monster
eyes II ran up behind me and but we in
the bunghole joannec ah helios running
nary films alright so the transmitter
the research hubs one I need what do I
need
hopefully that main building is now lit
up so maybe if I go back in there again
there will be something of value please
tell me that is correct if not I'm going
to stab a yak
come on get in there get in there
ah oppan Gangnam style we are back in
business
up up up up that person's dead let's see
if I got a heater in here cuz I off all
haha burn yes what did this do oh this
just led to another room by the way now
there are all these shower shower
gather gather ha ha does that do
residential wing was where am I
what's that behind her she's um alright
fine then these doors are gonna be
locked egg Oh
okay
ah that's creepy
oh hello the girl with the broken hip
what oh yeah that movie ah the book was
better in my why is that chair just
sitting here
yeah haha geez don't stand in the middle
Rama creeping me the hell out Jesus
doors locked cells a dark earlobe
right here ah computer tell me your
digital information Oh ain't that nice I
was wondering if we're still down for a
movie tonight no we're all dead lunch
Anton luminary scans foreign subjects
organic in nature ice core storage end
of the day sunflowers he waits in a
field
I heard that get some don't I'd rather
you didn't come get some cuz I'm one hit
away from me dead
where's that ding-dong damn heater hello
another computer tell me your secrets do
I need actually anything oh that is an
ugly dog adorable what ugly no not but
ugly but ugly as in also ugly oh hello
baby what are you doing here Clarice
okay transfer form someone wanted to get
the hell out of here no doubt heard
about my transfer loving me as much as I
loved you you abandoned her you dick or
lady I don't know I'm not really sure
could be Oh art all right so nothing
pertinent to my current Wow [ __ ] out now
emergency omaree
dad thank you Oh God
this game's gonna be the death of me
where am i where did I say oh yeah I
didn't save until after I went through
all of the rooms oh well I guess doesn't
matter pop out at night oh ah oh no turn
on or turn on turn on I see you there
I see you all right who's sobbing
sobbing oh my oh this is where I am okay
so that way is out this way I got it
going don't I all right I am a lot of
times so thank you all so much for
watching look forward to more this I'm
gonna fix this up as soon as I can so
thank you again and as always I will see
you in the next video bye bye
surprise [ __ ]